[Music]
this is a conference bike that Google
provides for employees to use around
campus my team specifically we regularly
get together and all seven of us will
pile on the bike and head down a couple
blocks to another cafe that's in another
building one of the fun natures of the
bike is the fact that not everybody is
facing the direction of the motion and
it's kind of surreal that you're putting
your basically your life in the drivers
hand and the driver basically can take
the advantage to warn you about speed
bombs or in warning about traffic at the
same time though there are cars in the
road so you get that experience back
with the driver where you get to warn
them about vehicles that are oncoming
part another you know team-building
nature of it is everybody doing to hand
signals to turn and make sure traffic is
is aware that you're doing something
that they might not be aware of I've
been here for quite a while and when I
joined we didn't have these bikes here
when these showed up it was quite a
surprise everybody kind like what is
that is that for a show is that for a
display and as we grew we actually got
more of them so there's I think more
than eight of these on campus that
employees can use it's definitely a
collaborative event
you